bonsoir mesdames et messieurs ici pas
très froid la campagne électorale
américaine arrive dans son dernier droit
ce soir on vous propose une émission
spéciale de deux heures
reportage sur le terrain analyse pour
mieux comprendre cette bataille
fascinante entre deux camps qui n'ont
jamais été aussi éloignées deux
amériques une élection
plus nos travaux
côté messieurs reste
oui oui
et qui voit les chômeurs
j'espère
vidéo ricard
des saisons amont des sésames échelle
comment on a pu en arriver là
une amérique on vient de le voir si
divisée avec à sa tête un président
totalement hors norme qui n'arrête pas
de nous surprendre il faut dire depuis
quatre ans ce soir on répondra à vos
questions merci de nous avoir écrit
d'ailleurs avec des analystes
et on ira à la rencontre de ces deux
amériques sur le terrain avec nos
équipes de reporters avec moi sur le
plateau le retour des plateaux mais à
deux mètres
rassurez vous car entre mon professeur
inversée de sherbrooke
madame prémont bonsoir bonsoir michels
et augé animateurs du midi info grand
passionné de politique américaine
correspondant à washington michel karine
première question que je vous pose est
ce que vous regardez images l'on regarde
ses divisions
est ce que ça vous inquiète un peu
situation de tensions raciales de
pandémie confusion peut-être sur
l'élection elle-même sur le vote par la
poste alors ça crée une situation
extrêmement volatile avec deux candidats
qui sont prêts à en découdre alors c'est
un peu inquiet tant cette année soit
celle ci y en avait vu d'autres celle là
est pas comme les autres elle est pas
comme les autres mai 68 c'est pas gai
non plus et les américains s'en sont
toujours sortis à la fin j'ai une espèce
de confiance en la démocratie américaine
malgré tout mes skis 13 ans b tard cette
année c'est qu'il ya un des deux
candidats qui ne s'est jamais engagé à
reconnaître le résultat de l'élection ni
la dernière fois
ni cette fois on va reparler de ce très
bientôt justement beaucoup de questions
du public là dessus monsieur tron ne
reconnaîtra jamais sa défaite et qui
écrivent nos téléspectateurs là qu'est
ce qui va arriver je vous présente à
greenville en caroline du sud michael
klaus ancien professeur de droit de
verser georges mehsud ce cross merci
d'être avec nous bonsoir je vous pose la
même question je vous pose la même
question êtes vous inquiet je suis
inquiet pour les mêmes raisons que vos
deux invités en studio je crois qu'il ya
grande possibilité de violence peu
importe qui gagne je suis pas d'accord
que 39
ne concédera pas s'il est défait par
contre 6,30 mène le soir des élections
et qu'après coup les votes postaux
postales sont comptés et que ça change
le résultat c'est là où je crains
le puits de violence de la part de la
gauche et de la droite
la différence avec 1968 à mon avis c'est
qu'en 68
on avait trois ou quatre réseaux de
télévision qui devait plaire à 200
millions d'américains tout le monde
recevait les nouvelles de la même source
quelque sorte les les journalistes
étaient modérés ne prenait pas partie
aujourd'hui on a des des douzaines des
centaines peut-être mais de sources
d'information électronique des gens
écoutent les informations qu'ils veulent
d'écouter ce ne sont pas toujours mais
même c'est pas souvent des propos
modérés
c'est des propos extrêmes bon mais
michael k je vais vous poser plus
directement la question c'est la
question qu'on a reçu en plus grand
nombre les gens sont inquiets qu'est ce
qui peut empêcher le président entre
hommes de s'accrocher au pouvoir
même s'il perd je conteste un peu la
prémisse la question je n'ai jamais vu
de preuve que monsieur trump se tiendra
au pouvoir s'il est défait si le soir
des élections
il est des faits il va concéder da c'est
un homme qui n'est pas un politicien
c'est un homme d'affaires il reviendrait
aux affaires très bien on va vous
appeler 3 novembre si jamais on a frôlé
de votre numéro
je souligne pour les gens la maison que
vous êtes républicains ne vous êtes
indécis on va y revenir on a on à la
soirée pour en parler je dirais carnot
le bon soir alors je vous pose la
question
réglons chat tout de suite qui va gagner
alors comment détruire une carrière en
direct ce soir avant de se prononcer sur
le résultat
je pense qu'on a beaucoup perdu d'argent
aux casinos des élections et que des
élections ont justement américaine sur
la question donc on va pas reprendre une
autre hypothèse pour essayer de régler
les dettes donc patrice on va se
positionner en fait sur ces fameux
sondages parce que c'est assez complexe
on va le voir pour l'instant si on se
tient au sondage à l'échelle nationale
des états unis
43% pour monsieur thiam 50,5 pour
monsieur by donne donc c'est quand même
une confortable avance de 7 % et demi
maintenant
ce qui est inquiétant pour le clan de
monsieur trump c'est qu'il ya vraiment
une tendance lourde depuis plusieurs
mois maintenant
monsieur tron n'a jamais été en avance
face à monsieur by donne
alors est ce que ça veut dire que ces
coulées dans le béton mais pas du tout
parce que regarder la carte des états
unis ce que vous veniez en rouge ce sont
les états qui votent habituellement pour
les républicains et qu'ils devraient
voter encore une fois cette fois ci pour
monsieur trump donc c'est vraiment le
midwest et le sud des états unis en bleu
vous avez sur la côte est et la côte
ouest donc les états qui habituellement
sont en faveur des démocrates mais ce
qui est important pour nous lors de
cette élection patrice évidemment ce
sont les fameux et tablent eux ce sont
les états move pardon les états pivots
les états clés alors il y en a six qu'on
va particulièrement suivre cette fois ci
il s'agit de l'arizona du oui ce concert
le michigan la pennsylvanie la caroline
du nord et bien sûr la floride pour
l'instant là aussi des sondages sont en
faveur de monsieur by donne mais on peut
dire que les marges sont quand même
assez disparate regardez par exemple la
caroline du nord 1,6 pour cent la
floride 2,7 pour ça on est vraiment dans
les marges d'erreur dont c'est vraiment
très hasardeux de se prononcer là dessus
donc si on regarde en fait ce qui s'est
passé en 2016 mais tous les sondages
avaient donné évidemment madame clinton
gagnante alors ils se sont largement
planté comme probablement nous aussi
également la difficulté des sondeurs
dans le fond c'est de savoir un peu qui
vote notamment dans les régions rurales
qui vote parmi les cols bleus et pour
qui ils votent et là il ya beaucoup
d'erreurs dans les sondeurs donc on
essaye cette fois-ci de corriger le tir
quatre ans plus tard c'est pas encore
clair mais une chose est sûre pas triste
c'est que cette torsion vraiment de
l'électorat des gens qui vont voter pour
trump peu importe les bévues des erreurs
les grossièretés qu'il va commettre
ils vont quand même voté pour lui parce
que c'est le messie et là on a 25 à 30%
les américains qui vont suivre
quoi qu'il arrive ce qu'ils voient
capable de convaincre d'autres personnes
des familles des voisins des amis ou
bien restez chez eux ça c'est le gros
point d'interrogation le voit tous les
scandales tous les faux pas n'ont pas
suffi à réduire ce ce 30 % solide pour
dungeon d'ailleurs sophie langlois c'est
intéressant est allé en pennsylvanie à
la rencontre de ses électeurs qui votent
dans notre choix
ce n'est pas un hasard s'ils se doit est
de la pennsylvanie est devenue une des
régions les plus industrielles des états
unis c'est ici qu'est né au xixème
siècle l'industrie du pétrole et du
charbon
cette énergie a attiré de grandes
musiques dassier est le premier syndicat
des stats est fier de nous montrer son
train électrique neuf ans qui lui
rappelle les nombreuses voies ferrées
construite réparé par sa compagnie
beaucoup de trains de charbon et d'acier
ont circulé sur les rails d'atlas
shrugged l'entreprise a été fondée par
son père un démocrate bleu foncé comme
toute la famille à l'époque une
ici les allégeances politiques sont
étroitement liées aux mouvements de
l'économie tant que les cheminées des
usines bruller pleine capacité
le parti démocrate proche des syndicats
étaient largement majoritaires
puis le libre échange et la concurrence
de l'asie ont entraîné des mises à pied
massives et missing est bernadette une
autre ancien démocrate
elle avait écrit à bill clinton et à
barack obama après les tueries à l'école
columbine et à celle de 110 groupes
centaine jazz triste détonne
elle a annoncé in town découragé de voir
les démocrates ne rien faire pour éviter
d'autres tueries dans les écoles
l'ancien secrétaire médicale s'y laisser
charmer par une vedette du petit écran
out britannique qui enseigne au
préscolaire a toujours voté républicain
cette fois ci la sécurité de ses enfants
et l'enjeu le plus important pour elle
la mère de famille jusque son pays n'a
jamais été aussi divisés par deux
je pense aussi que 30 a sa part de
responsabilité 10e candidat républicain
comment un autre ancien militaire devenu
analyste financier et commerçant robe en
tweed et plan la partisanerie qui
déchire son pays les pousses du club et
sa partenaire en affaires n'approuve pas
le ton belliqueux du président trump
mais elle estime qu'il est favorable aux
femmes tubize à 3 3 m eur
c'est à saxe
il n'y a pas que des patrons qui ont
abandonné le parti démocrate en
pennsylvanie les ouvriers qui gagne 80 à
100 mille dollars par année estimé trop
payés trop tard que jamais mais gagneur
c'est vraiment intéressant dans le topo
de sophie tous les mots clés ont été
entendus loin de taxes donc moins d'état
pro-vie les armes
cet homme qui dit quelque chose
d'extraordinaire karine prémont je vous
entends de la tuer dit il ya peut-être
pas réussi à ramener les emplois ils
nous écoutent
il y aura essayé ces gens là se sentent
écoutés
oui parce que tout homme parle
essentiellement des préoccupations ces
gens là des emplois les taxes les impôts
l'économie est évidemment les démocrates
depuis quelques années ont donné
l'impression de s'être éloigné un peu de
ça pour aborder des enjeux plus globaux
plus internationaux l'environnement par
exemple les affaires internationales
alors on a l'impression qu'elle chantait
connecter aux préoccupations des gens on
a faut voir la réalité aussi versus la
perception mais c'est au moins la
perception de ses jambes
mais c'est fort long le voile cette dame
ce monsieur qui se fient a effectivement
lui dit mais les emplois sont parvenus
ils disposent grave
ils réagissaient et xavier sauf que à un
moment donné promettre de revenir dans
le bon vieux temps c'est pas toujours
quelque chose qu'on est capable de
livrer des mines de charbon il y en a
peut-être une ou deux qui aurait
ouvertes mais il ya charbon ne sera plus
ce qu'il était l'exemple le plus
frappant c'est que musée du charbon au
kentucky et maintenant il est sauvé il
est trouvé mon énergie solaire mais
c'est c c'est ce retour en arrière que
les troupes ont réussi à armes à
remâcher il ya 4 1 ça va quand même être
plus difficile parce que la noix qui
répondent à la question il ya promis des
emplois qui sont contenus web en verrons
comment ça ça joue ça le soir de
l'élection mccall crasse on a
l'impression qu'il ya un niveau au
rationnel michel le dilemmien de charbon
il ya des faits mais un niveau émotif
l'oeil en relation et motive le
président tchèque avec ces électeurs là
c'est un type de l'extérieur ce type qui
n'a pas été politiciens toute sa vie
ce qui fait vraiment grande différence
avec byden évidemment ce type qui part
lorsqu'il pense à quelque chose même si
c'est une pensée qui est primitive ou
naïve il le dit il ya des gens surtout
des cols bleus qui aime bien ça qui aime
bien que ce soit un type qui dit ce
qu'il pense qu'ils aimaient des
promesses et qui tente et c'est ça qui
est important
il donne l'impression de tenter
d'accomplir ses promesses là et oui
effectivement je pense que ça résonne
beaucoup avec avec bien des gens il faut
pas car elle vraiment minimiser aux
états unis l'impact bon de position pro
vie il ya beaucoup de gens aux états
unis qui veulent qu'ils ont peur de la
nomination de juge trop sans trou trop à
gauche donc pour eux ne serait-ce que ça
ils vont mettre la croix devant monsieur
jobs mais encore une fois c'est pas de
majorité d'américains qui pensent alors
il ya toujours une instrumentalisation
aussi de ces gens qui ont des
convictions profondes parce que c'est
les gens qui vont davantage gothiques
sont davantage des militants sur le
terrain aussi alors on a besoin de ces
gens là et de leur mobilisation
vous l'avez dit tantôt ce sont des mots
clés justement pour faire ressortir un
peu la fibre la fibre militante des gens
mais c'est pour ça michelle puis freiné
car nous nous montrer les chiffres c'est
pour ça qu'ils il est pas en chute libre
il n'est pas juste libre remarqué
patrice une élection une grosse grosse
victoire électorale aux etats-unis c'est
60 44 guen avait gagné 49 états sur 50
il y avait eu 68 60 % du vote et sur
l'adversaire ce modèle avait eu 40
associés
c'est toujours comme ça alors la base
républicaine qui ne bougera pas de si
mal tu peux pas aller plus bas
ces 40 monsieur monsieur réussi à en
avoir un peu plus que ça mais pas
beaucoup plus jusqu'à maintenant on le
voit c'est au tour de 42 43 dans les
sondages ça peut changer évidemment on
fera pas l'erreur de 4 mais il reste que
les sondages ont été claires des
sondages nationaux à 3 depuis pas mal le
début de
de cette année et encore plus avec la
pandémie parce que ça c'est vraiment le
boulet au pied de donald trump et encore
cette semaine on a vu qu'il y aura
beaucoup de misère à se sortir et ça on
va y revenir un peu plus tard
l'éléphant dans la pièce et qui sera
capable entre bayonne et lui de dire je
vais vous relancer l'économie après la
pandémie celui qui sera capable de
passer ce message le risque peut-être de
l'emporter michael quand je reviens vers
les cas la question que vous que vous
trouviez exagéré parce que vous nous
avez dit tout à l'heure il va
reconnaître une défaite
il va passer à autre chose il va
retourner en affaires j'ai une question
de patrick la liberté qui revient à la
charge
il dit beaucoup craignent une guerre
civile
là vous trouvez que les gens exagèrent
là on est on dérape
mais là la guerre civile là on parle
d'autre chose qu'on ne pas pas de trump
qui qui refusent une défaite on parle de
la population américaine qui l'appuient
qui refuseraient sa défaite
et là je suis d'accord avec michel
serrault j'ai la démocratie américaine
est plus forte que ça je ne crois pas
qu'il y aura guerre civile ce qu'il y
aura à mon avis c'est désordre surtout
dans les grandes villes
on le voit il ya des ordres actuellement
et ça c'est quelque chose dont trempe
profite actuellement parce que chacune
de ces grandes villes est une
ce sont des grandes villes dirigées par
des démocrates ce sont souvent des des
gens qui sont des des professionnels
disons des révolutionnaires qui tentent
de profiter du désordre pour brûler pour
tuer pour saccager des magasins et il
risque d'y avoir ça si tu remportes
l'élection si par contre bayonne
remportent les élections il ya toujours
cette petite minorité d'extrème droite
qui peut accomplir la même chose donc
guerre civile absolument pas d ordre et
violences pendant quelques jours je le
crains
je n'anticipe même très bien michel un
petit mot la thur faut quand même
remarquer que monsieur thuram joue la
carte de la loi et l'ordre
depuis trois mois depuis le 1er juin
quand il avait fait nettoyer le pacte
devant la maison blanche puis la faire
avec la bible est là et ça n'a pas fait
bouger les huit des sondages ça n'a pas
fait bouger l'aiguillé
peut-être que ça n est fait sous terrain
dans l'électorat et son le verra aux
urnes mais jusqu'à maintenant ça ne
paraît pas on va y revenir à son nhât
d'un segment justement et je vais vous
poser la question plus tard est-ce que
le thème malgré tout la loi et l'ordre
peut pas à aider les républicains dans
certains coins mais après la pause
mesdames et messieurs il ya un état qui
fascina en 2000 savez rendu fou
l'amérique au complet à des mois la
dernière fois extrêmement serré remporté
de justesse par les républicains c'est
la floride
on y on vous en parle de l'importance et
à qui
le
un état clé aussi appelé à pivot où est
ta charnière est un état américain qui
n'est acquis à aucun parti lors de
l'élection présidentielle les tacles et
est souvent représentée en violet
puisque son allégeance varie au fil des
élections
ils ne sont ni plein couleurs démocrates
ni rouge couleur des républiques est le
résultat du vote dans un état clé est
déterminant le soir de l'élection le
parti qui récolte le plus de voix même
une infime majorité rapporte sauf de
rares exceptions tous les votes des
grands électeurs de cet état
ce sont ces grands électeurs qui élisent
ensuite officiellement le président les
états clés sont les véritables champs de
bataille de l'élection présidentielle
evènement campagne publicité les
candidats y investissent beaucoup de
temps et beaucoup d'argent cette année
il faudra particulièrement surveiller
six états pivots la floride caroline du
nord la pennsylvanie le michigan le
winsconsin et l'arizona tous rapportés
par donald huard
il ya quatre ans pour l'instant joe
biden est en avance dans la majorité de
ces états mais la lutte s'annonce serrée
oui parce que frédéric arnaud elle nous
l'a bien dit tout à l'heure michel ces
objets vous rappeler ce souvent votre
émission aussi on est dans les états
clés dans la marge d'erreur on ne sait
pas qui va remporter pour l'instant
c'est état est un état qu'on va
surveiller en particulier qui est
durement frappée par la coved
c'est un état clé c'est la floride en
2016 comme l'a emporté par seulement 113
mais le voit sur l'arrêt clinton
c'est moins de 2% des voix sur place
notre correspondant jean françois
bélanger
derniers préparatifs avant le départ que
party game attendait depuis très
longtemps
une parade la bad en l'homme du
président
la fondatrice des femmes de floride pour
toi n'a pas ménagé ses efforts pour
réunir le plus grand nombre de bateaux
possible sur la côte d'émeraude
des centaines d'embarcations venues de
partout en floride et des états voisins
doute aux couleurs de dans le temps
démonstration de force à deux mois des
élections
anne est une fan de la première heure
idolâtre dans le top depuis près de dix
ans à ses yeux les démocrates
représentent une grave menace pour
l'avenir des états unis le défilé est un
succès il a rassemblé selon les
organisateurs plus de 1500 bateau
l'occasion d'envoyer un message clair le
nord ouest de la floride
très conservateur reste fidèle à d'antan
la bataille électorale qui joue ici est
loin d'être anodine car avec son poids
démographique
la floride est de loin l'état pivot le
plus important est pour dans notre
chambre
c'est même essentiel impossible pour lui
de penser renouveler son bail à la
maison blanche sont gagnants floride
aucun républicain ni est arrivé en prêt
de 100 ans
or depuis quelques mois laissez une
inquiétante pour le camp de roms se
multiplient en floride
le scrutin est toujours très serré et se
joue souvent à moins de 1% à quelques
milliers de votes les indépendants les
non affiliés font souvent pencher la
balance
mais pour gagner ici dans notre chambre
doit d'abord garder ses appuis s'assurer
que les républicains fassent bloc
derrière lui
et difficile de faire plus républicain
que ron philippe koch qui met depuis
quatre ans ron ne reconnaît plus son
parti n'a rien eu conservateur sa morale
de vie sa gestion de l'économie
sa vision de la diplomatie autant
d'éléments qui selon lui le disqualifie
alors pour la première fois de sa vie
ron philip cox qui votera démocrate
mais la floride c'est aussi le paradis
des retraités un des états qui compte la
plus forte proportion d'électeurs âgés
ses lecteurs
généralement plus conservateurs et ceux
qui habitent au fait les deux ne font
pas exception
c'est un endroit à nul autre pareil
qu'une sorte de disneyland pour
retraités avec ses 54 terrain de golf
c'est la xè ménagers et ses bâtiments
qui ressemble à des décors de cinéma
âge minimum 55 ans les enfants sont
éperdument
comme tout le monde ici christelle et se
déplace en voiturette de golf
mais son soutien affiché aux candidats
démocrates lui vaut bien des insultes
car malgré leurs allures paisible les v
les deux sont le théâtre d'une bataille
électorale âprement discutés batailles
menées comme tout le reste ici en
voiturette de golf trice ce c'est très
minoritaire ici mais elle sent un début
de changement à cause entre autres du
coronavirus déjà 650 mille cas en
floride et douze mille morts
l'apparition progressive des masses qui
s'y révèle une inquiétude grandissante
larinto rhys davies ont tous 2 81 ans et
n'osent plus sortir de chez eux sans se
couvrir le visage tout deux républicains
ils vont voter contre 90 champions en
bonne partie en raison de sa gestion des
affections qui reste peut-être marginal
mais que stan lee en est convaincu plus
que jamais en floride sur votre compte
dans chaque camp la prudence reste de
mise il reste encore près de deux mois
avant l'élection
et d'ici là beaucoup d'eau va encore
couler sous les ponts
à la question qu'on peut se poser at il
bien géré cette pandémie il y en a un
autre plus grave qui se pose depuis hier
at il menti aux américains extraits de
livres du livre cd entrevue que bob
woodward a fait avec le président veut
l'entendre le président qui raconte à
word on est en février qu'il sait dans
le fond que c'est très grave
michael krumm je vous pose la question
at il d'abord la question plus générale
at il bien géré la crise mais a t'il en
plus menti aux américains d'après vous à
mon avis non il n'a pas menti je
répondrai donc à cette question en
premier si on écoute tout l'entrevue et
d'ailleurs je crois que bob woodward ne
crois pas qu'il a menti sea world avait
cru que l'homme avait mal géré avait
menti et est en train de mentir au
peuple américain il aurait révélé cette
nouvelle là il ya cinq mois lorsque
l'entrevue a eu lieu si au lieu de ça il
a attendu jusqu'à aujourd'hui la
parution de son livre ce que tu as passé
de faire ce que les présidents toujours
essayé de faire lorsqu'il ya une crise
c'est de calmer le peuple américain de
ne pas créer de ne pas de ne pas crier
feu crier au feu pour que les gens
commencent à s'affoler donc j'ai
l'impression que d'ici une semaine ou
deux semaines
cette nouvelle en particulier sera
disparu ok quant à l'autre question est
ce qu'il adopte des corps non mais c'est
ça gérer de 4 à l'éducation plus
globalement on vous entendu sur goodwill
est-ce qu'il est bien gérée a bien géré
par essayer vous êtes le pire pays sur
la planète actuellement à mon avis n'a à
ma connaissance j'ai parlé d'années
devant moi on n'est pas le pire pays sur
la planète mais ça c'est une écoute et
j'ai bien lu
les opinions des dirigeants de la suède
de la france
différentes méthodes ont été tentées
dans différents pays avec un succès
modéré plus ou moins aujourd'hui
actuellement aux etats unis le taux
d'infection est en baisse il ya des
états où les taux d'infection était très
élevé au début comme new york enverrait
vous ne vous ne le vous ne mangerez
partie là ni bien ni mal géré il y là il
a commis des erreurs il a fait il est
fait de son mieux
très bien michel sauget
écoutez monsieur tram pas dit aussi ça
va disparaître comme par magie il a dit
vous allez voir en avril ça va s'en
aller quand il va commencer à faire beau
il a pas juste essayer de ne pas semer
la panique qui a essayé de minimiser et
ça c'est indéniable et d'autre part il
ne pourra écouter les scientifiques du
gouvernement américain le docteur fao
cheadle est complètement passée 3 pts ne
le voit plus ne le rencontrent plus de
lui parle plus alors à un moment donné
dire qu'il ya bien géré cette crise
l'embarqué vol on n'est peut-être pas
placé pour parler de la de la gestion
des autres nous on est au québec où ça
va peut-être pas été extraordinaire mais
cela dit je dire il était possible de
nier que monsieur tron
à un moment donné et à et à de
nombreuses reprises audi il n'y a pas de
problème avec ça vous allez voir ça va
bien aller
et ça va se régler vous êtes d'accord
avec ça car elle vraiment il là il
aurait pu disons le comme sont mieux
gérées et mieux accueillir la science
dans son cas ne serait ce qu'à dire la
vérité aux gens ne serait ce parce que
ont des bons il n'a pas voulu créer la
panique mais dans la plupart des autres
pays on a dit la vérité aux gens et
c'est ce qui a permis de sauver des vies
aussi à différents degrés effectivement
les mesures sont pas parfaites partout
mais on n'a pas besoin de bab oddworld
pour savoir que il n'a pas dit la vérité
aux gens il est en minimisant cette
crise là ça a eu des répercussions
majeures ça fait en sorte que les
mesures ont été plus difficiles à mettre
en place quand il y en a eu et donc ça
envoyait un message confus à la
population merkel parce que
je posais la question de la gestion a
fédéré 4 avec arnaud les etats unis sont
le pays le plus touché
patrice c'est le triste record
évidemment du nombre de cas aux états
unis
les faits sont là malheureusement pour
eux il ya quand même plus de 6 millions
391 milka et ça continue d'augmenter
jour après jour le nombre des décès
aussi évidemment est très inquiétant
plus de 190 mille morts ce qui veut dire
que dans les prochaines semaines on va
probablement arriver aux deux cent mille
morts et ça dans l'état actuel des
choses ça veut dire qu'un décès sur cinq
à cause de la qu'ovide dans le monde a
eu lieu aux états unis si on regarde
également toutes ces statistiques on se
rencontre dans le fond que l'aco vide
aux états unis est devenue la troisième
cause de décès après les maladies
cardiaques et après le cancer c'est
quand même pas négligeable
évidemment alors l'évolution c'est vrai
que il y a une certaine baisse du nombre
de cas aux etats-unis dans certains
états par contre garder cette carte qui
est intéressant plus on va vers l'orangé
et le rouge plus on a d une
recrudescence des foyers d'éclosion des
foyers de contamination
ce qui veut dire que on si on se
rappelle de la carte tantôt on est
vraiment dans les états plus rouge le
midwest le sud dans les états
républicains
quel va être l'impact à ce moment là
dans ces états là d'écouté pour
l'instant au niveau de la gestion de la
pandémie à 56% les américains qui
désapprouvent la façon dont donald trump
a géré ce dossier là sauf que l'émission
s'appelle deux amériques une élection
regardez du côté des républicains ont
dit il n'ya pas d'avoir l'amm monsieur
tram fait ce qu'il peut mais chez les
démocrates c'est une véritable
catastrophe alors qu'est-ce qui va
gagner dans ces deux là c'est vraiment
très partagés dernière petite chose il
ya toujours une petite surprise
d'octobre parfois lors des élections et
cette fois ci ce qui pourrait peut-être
aider monsieur trump si jamais ça arrive
c'est peut-être la mise en marché du
fameux vaccin
oui mais c'est peu probable lui parle
d'octobre mais des grandes
pharmaceutiques ont fait publier une
page de publicité dans les grands
journaux américains hier en disant ne
vous en faites pas cher peuple américain
et population mondiale
nous n'allons pas brûler les étapes on
verra mais ça serait une immense
surprise michel s'est dit choqué je dois
je vais vous parler d'environnement la
carte que federico montré
d'intéressantes dans le sud des états
unis on ne réussit
au delà de la politique avec la coved le
fait de porter un masque
monsieur tron en a fait quelque chose
d'un geste politique si vous portez un
masque vous êtes contre lui si vous ne
portez pas encore cette semaine à la
maison blanche a demandé aux
journalistes qui voulaient y poser des
question d'enlever leurs masques il ya
politisé même cette question la question
des jeunes et que donahue sur
l'environnement on a l'impression que ce
évacués mais regardez ces images
j'allais dire extraordinaire oui dans le
vrai sens du mot impressionnant san
francisco qui ressemble à un four
littéralement laquelle la californie qui
brûle avec vingt fois plus détendu brûlé
par rapport aux feux de l'an dernier
donc question monsieur donahue
l'environnement occupera-t-il une place
prépondérante pour les américains dans
la campagne je commence avec vous un
michael gracey ce que c'est un sujet qui
va compte tenu de ces flux en plus cela
émerger écoutez il ya peut-être la
tentation de la part de certaines
personnes de tout blâme et tout ce qui
ne va pas sur donald trump et et
j'ajoute que je suis pas amateur 2 dont
la trame vous le savez patrice je suis
indécis moi même je me trouve obligée de
le défendre un peu c'est pas lui qui a
causé les feux des
les feux de forêt c'était
une éclair qui a causé le feu de forêt à
san francisco non mais l'économie jusque
là je vous demande pour répondre à votre
question je vous dis oui à la vie
est ce que le sujet de l'environnement
va s'imposer croyez vous je ne crois pas
d'accord il ya tellement d'autres sujets
qu'ils soient plus importants
actuellement chelsea et l'environnement
crise climatique
on a l'impression que ce n'est plus sur
le radar c'est pas sur le radar parce
que déjà ça très bien les positions des
deux candidats ils sont irréconciliables
c'est pas parce qu'on en parle pas que
c'est pas une préoccupation pour
beaucoup d'électeurs mais vraiment
là-dessus baden et robes aux dépositions
complètement inconscient
on va le dire tout de suite pendant un
tableau à la toute fin mais ce bail
donne voudrait réintégrer la corderie
l'accord de paris mais se trompe
évidemment est sorti sortie de son pays
l'accord de paris monsieur bart hayden
propose un quart bonheur en 2050 marqué
qu'un peu beaucoup beaucoup dirigeants
ou et promettent sans donner de détails
car un prénom n'empêche changement
climatique pour toute une génération
c'est important oui on ne retrouve pas
ça effectivement dans les sujets dans
les grands sondages je pense c'est le
26e sujet l'économie santé nomination
des juges à la cour suprême et ses
environnements c'est comme 26e oui
c'était très important pendant les
élections mi-mandat en 2018 et beaucoup
de jeunes élus qui ont été justement il
lui par la jeune génération notamment
sur cette préoccupation là mais cette
année évidemment avec la pandémie avec
les problèmes économiques dont on
comprend que ça a été relégué
effectivement au 20e rang mais en même
temps je peux tout à fait d'accord pour
revenir sur ce que dit monsieur crans
sur la responsabilité ou non de chaume
parce que c'est quand même quelqu'un qui
est le mien climato sceptiques à la tête
de l'agencé environnementale c'est quand
même quelqu'un qui a aboli plusieurs
règlements sur les questions
environnementales et qui a des finances
et
beaucoup de programmes environnementaux
aussi et justement parlé de charbon
tantôt ce genre d'énergie là et pas très
est pas très bon pour l'environnement
non plus donc
mais on n'en parlera pas beaucoup
pendant la campagne on en parle
généralement très peut de toute façon
d'environnement pendant les campagnes et
je pense que cette année il ya d'autres
sujets qui vont l'éclipsé oui et puis
d'ailleurs avant de faire la morale aux
américains chez nous oui on en a parlé
mais disons que ça prêté leurs traits
powder déterminant dans les deux
dernières campagnes électorales québec
et canada mac race est ce que pour
monsieur tron dans le fond c'est pas
sorcier la lui dire on a des ressources
on va les exploiter puis la science va
trouver éventuellement des solutions la
dernière fois que j'ai regardé il se
fait quelques semaines j'avoue les etats
unis ont diminué la production
l'émission des émissions charbon plus
que tous les autres pays de lure de
l'occident c'est vrai qu'il a sorti les
états unis de l'accord de paris
d'ailleurs 30 n'est pas les accords
internationaux de toutes façons comme
vous le savez mais il aime bien les
accords bilatéraux mines et il n'aime
pas les accords multilatéraux
mais l'entreprise privée tesla et tous
les autres l'arrivée de voitures
électriques et cetera ham a produit des
résultats à côté côté émissions c'est
pas des résultats gouvernementaux et
vous le savez vaut entre les entrevues
que vous avez diffusé il ya quelques
minutes et montrer qu'il ya bien des
citoyens qui disent écoutez laisser
l'entreprise privée s'occuper de ça
c'est pas le gouvernement qui va nous
dicter quoi faire et il ya un sentiment
qui est pas mal répondu je veut boucler
la boucle avant de passer à la pause on
va parler d'économie après la pause
gérald sera avec nous d'ailleurs parce
qu'il se pose en champion de l'économie
d'ailleurs les sondages le montrent
c'est la question où il bat byden à peu
près à toutes les fois mais je reviens
la floride avant de fermer cette
parenthèse
qu'est ce que vous pensez puis je ne
joue pas ou de 20 la main
ça va être encore extrêmement serré
michel c'est toujours extrêmement serré
souvenez-vous de 2000 et c'est vraiment
une bataille des régions plus rurales de
la floride contre les grandes villes il
ya de très grandes villes la floride
miami évidemment qui est une mégalopole
et c'est là que ça joue il faut faire
attention justement dans le comptage des
voix comme un bureau scrutin et rural ça
se compte vite le soir de l'élection la
floride peut aller du côté de monsieur
tron est rendu au lendemain matin au
surlendemain être passé du côté
démocrate
c'est une des possibilités cette année
ça ouais d'ailleurs ça j'ouvre une
parenthèse fort importante pour les gens
qui nous écoutent qui vont suivre cette
campagne électorale jusqu'au 3 novembre
c'est possible qu'elle ne se termine pas
le droit en novembre car une pré monde
c'est très possible c'est ce que
plusieurs craignent j'ose dire ce bon là
parce que ça pourrait s'étirer sur
plusieurs jours voire une semaine sinon
plus parce qu'il y ait des votes qui
vont arriver par la poste aussi en
quantité plus importante que d'habitude
ça peut prendre quelques jours à compter
les votes alors à partir de ce moment là
on aurait probablement pas de résultats
trop en avant les conservateurs sur la
petite bien patrice on va passer nuit là
on vous expliquera michael caze à la
peau on a passé une nuit à élire un chef
conservateur
il ya peu de temps au canada alors très
bien
après la pause les inégalités
économiques c'est important l'écart
entre les riches et les pauvres s'est
creusé émilie dubreuil est allé en
californie vous allez voir c'est
impressionnant
sauf erreur c'est devenu un grand
classique de la politique est ce que
vous êtes mieux maintenant qu'il y a
quatre ans la fameuse question de ronald
reagan se posent encore à toutes les
élections
l'économie c'est la clé et didier
economy stupid comme l'avait dit james
carville un stratège à l'époque de bill
clinton
gerald bonsoir bonsoir alors est ce que
monsieur choï et dans les faits le grand
champion économique qu'il prêterait
jusqu'au 1er mars
il pouvait revendiquer ce titre là bien
sûr la coved 19 à changer tous partout
dans le monde y compris aussi aux états
unis mais je pense qu'il faut quand même
se rappeler que le président trempette
arrive en 2016-2017 slr d'aller de
l'économie américaine qui s'est quand
même poursuivi parce qu après la grande
crise financière de 2008 2009 on a
rétabli l'économie et donc tous les
signaux sont devenus au vert pendant à
peu près une décennie et le président a
profité de cela quand même la baisse des
impôts à aider la croissance économique
surtout de 2010 8 3% d'augmentation du
produit intérieur brut mais 2020 on va
oublier sa 2020 - 6 5 % en raison de la
cofidis pas de sa faute s'il faut
exactement et les trois premières années
c'est un peu plus fort que le deuxième
mandat de barack obama l'emploi et la
question de l'emploi est très importante
le taux de chômage est tombé à un creux
record de 3 5% sous la présidence de
tram on est passé de 4,7 à 3.5 un bond à
cause la coved à 15%
on a redescendu à 8 4% il ya onze
millions cinq cent mille américains qui
n'ont pas encore retrouvé d'emploi en
raison de la crise ça c'est un chiffre
tellement important 11 millions de
familles qui se demande qui des deux va
mieux relancer l'économie post coville
et cette partie là sera particulièrement
difficile d'aller rechercher les emplois
perdus c'est la dernière partie qui sera
la plus difficile déficit commercial il
ventait beaucoup
de remettre de l'ordre dans le commerce
mondial qu'il allait donner faire la
leçon à tout le monde est ce que le
déficit commercial s'est amélioré alors
des confié avec le canada avec la
renégociation de l'alena avec l'europe
et avec la chine surtout l'objectif
était de faire baisser les importations
chinoises
la coved à aider mais dans la première
partie on a vu quand même le déficit
commercial augmenter et les revenus
essentiellement au point 520 milliards
de déficit commercial avec le monde le
point qu'on avait au début de la
présidence d'honneur
il aime beaucoup dire la bourse exploser
la bourse même exactement si son
éducateur préféré la bourse poursuivi sa
croissance durant le premier mandat du
président entre hommes
il ya eu un effondrement au printemps
raison de la crise bien sûr de 30-35
pour ça une reprise ensuite depuis on a
effacé à peu près tout les pas les
pertes
je vous signale que qui profitent de
cette hausse là ce sont les plus riches
bien sûr les 10% les plus riches qui
détiennent 80% de la richesse nette des
ménages aux états unis parce que je veux
terminer là dessus quand on regarde les
inégalités c'est un vieux problème
américain qui existait sous clinton sous
obama sous 30 également regarder les
revenus moyens en jaune les livres les
ménages à revenus moyens avait une part
de 60 2% de la richesse des ménages aux
états unis hommes de samson et 10 et
baissé à 43 % et les revenus élevés sont
passés d'une part de 29 à 40 8 %
ce graphique là ce tableau mme la montre
clairement que le problème des
inégalités a continué de grandir durant
la présidence de monsieur tron
merci beaucoup gerald très clair donc
dans sept plus grandes économies du
monde mesdames et messieurs émilie
dubreuil est allé en californie et a vu
comme c'est le cas dans plusieurs états
des poches de pauvreté inacceptable
un divorce une dépression des rixes ou a
fait naufrage
ici dans les bidonvilles d'auckland que
l'on retrouve partout sur le bord des
autoroutes sous les viaducs dans les
quartiers industriels
comme les milliers de chinois les
parents de derrick immigrés dans la
région de san francisco au détour de la
seconde guerre mondiale animé du rêve
américain
sans se douter qu'un jour leur fils leur
est plutôt du côté de son cauchemar
depuis 2010 est la population sans abri
a plus que doublé à houplines dans sept
villes de quatre cent trente mille
habitants considérés comme une banlieue
de san francisco on estime qu'il y
aurait au moins 5000 personnes sans
logis et que des milliers d'autres
vivent dans la misère
non stop depuis le début de la pandémie
c'est l'hécatombe tout baigne si les
loyers sont si chères à oak lindsey que
le rêve américain existe bel et bien
tout à côté il fait du jogging du
shopping du surf
il prend du bon temps sur la plage à bt
maison avec vue imprenable sur la mer
le rêve américain des nouvelles
technologies à bétous dans la région ça
vaut charles maison ça vaut dans les
millions certainement la maison moyenne
cote au dessus d'un point 5 millions on
est dans palo alto qui est un des
centres
l'ateq la californie beaucoup de gens
qui travaillent dans la tech vivent ici
laurence du saut à 27 ans elle travaille
comme journaliste au mercury news le
journal de silicon valley son
affectation sont vite comme on dit dans
le métier les inégalités sociales
elle ne couvre que ça dans le problème
n'est pas tant une structure entre ceux
qui ont le plus ceux qui ont le moins
ceux qui ont le plus les milliards vers
la californie airs l'instant 66,6 en
fait 135 milliards depuis le début la
pandémie et de l'autre côté on a un
california et sur cinq qui a demandé de
chômage en 2018 pour la première fois
dans l'histoire du pays les américains
les plus riches ont tous y payer moins
d'impôts que les plus pauvres le
résultat d'une réforme fiscale de
l'administration trump et l'état de la
californie il favorise aussi les plus
nantis l'est
la taxation des riches qui permet aux
marques ce docteur bob dylan morrs que
ce monde 200 fischer est d'avoir une
très très grande valeur nette
en fait sans que cette valeur le soient
taxés du coût des moines équipe devrait
tuer mais qu elle ne pourrait pour
dans les faubourgs d'auckland
joe qui vit dans un parc de roulottes
déglingué trouve que cette injustice est
tout naturel
il est décevant
dans un campement humides des rixes ou
ne peut lui s'empêcher de rêver d'une
amérique plus juste une californie où un
milliard engrangé par les géants de la
tech servirait à construire des
logements pour des gens comme lui les
dormeurs le sans abri n'a plus rien mais
il a gardé des aspirations et les
candidats à la mairie d'auckland
une course qui aura lieu en 2022 alors
on lui souhaite d'abord bel et bien de
ce prêt de se présenter et de se faire
élire question de robert jobidon le
fossé se creuse entre riches et pauvres
aux états unis pourquoi la question n'a
tels que peu de place dans le discours
des leaders politiques
j'en profite pour accueillir en direct
de new york timothy naftali historien
professeur verte in new york
naftali je vais commencer donc avec vous
à ce que ces questions là comme
l'environnement ne parle un peu plus tôt
nous finalement on en parle mais pas
vraiment c'est une des grandes questions
des analystes politiques ici aux
etats-unis et même les analystes
ailleurs c'est pourquoi est ce que les
gens qui sont pauvres pourquoi est ce
que les membres de la classe ouvrière
par exemple à vote pour à des candidats
killer qui quiconque qui donne des
promesses de baisser l'impôt sur les
riches
pourquoi les jeux les gens ne votent pas
pour leurs intérêts ou ne votent pas à a
fait de tes d'améliorer leurs intérêts
économiques
les intérêts personnels c'est une grande
question on l'a vu aux états unis depuis
les années soixante dix à l'augmentation
de deux grands cause culturelle sociale
à des causeries
et de temps en temps les analystes
pensent que les jambes
ah les pauvres où les membres de la
classe ouvrière votre seule pas pour
dick sur les questions économiques mais
sur des questions culturelles et c'est
une des conclusions des reposes possible
à cette bonne question
michael braun est ce que dans nos rues
de rome et je rappelle pour les gens qui
n'étaient pas avec nous plutôt vous êtes
républicain pas certain de voter pour
toi mais cette fois ci mais vous êtes
républicain est ce que le parti
républicain a tourné le dos à ses poches
de pauvreté qui demandent plus d'état
donc qui demandent des logements sociaux
qui demandent de l'aide plus plus
important il ya des problèmes complexes
il n'ya pas seulement un problème le
manque d'argent il ya le problème de
sans abri surtout en californie
à cause du zonage en californie la
maison moyenne comme votre reportage l'a
indiqué la maison moyenne coûte plus
qu'une demi million dans tout l'état il
est difficile donc pour les gens de la
classe ouvrière de trouver du logement
ça c'est pas une question fédéral ça
c'est une question d'aménagement du
terrain c'est une question de l'état
pour l'état de californie
par contre je dois vous dire que lorsque
monsieur trump a été élu à mon avis l'un
de ses plus grands succès a été
d'abaisser les taux d'impôts les taux
marginaux d'impôts pour tous pas
seulement pour les riches et c'est ce
qui a amené à cette croissance dont
votre votre reporter a parlé le taux de
chômage les plus bas jamais produit
lorsque le taux de chômage le taux de
chô mage noir par exemple est le plus
bas qui l'a jamais été
même chose pour les hispanophones sas a
affecté les pauvres sas affecte les
pauvres merci car entre mons et c'est
l'argument de dancho monza d'ailleurs il
dit j'en ai fait plus pour la communauté
noire que que tous les président avant
un mois peut-être sauve abraham lincoln
mais sérieusement il dit que le taux de
chômage qui baisse à être tout le monde
c'était ça son argument son argument est
en même temps quand vous avez montré les
chiffres tantôt avec gerald pillon ce
qu'on voyait c'était qui avait déjà sept
ans
cela préalablement à leur choix pas
réussi à conserver cette tendance là je
devrais peut-être revenir à ce qu'on
disait tantôt sur cet écart entre les
riches et les pauvres pour oublier que
si l'idée très ancrée chez les
américains que l'individualisme que
cette idée qu'il faut se construire nous
mêmes il faut réussir par nous même si
on travaille fort si on était si on est
on saisit les opportunités on va réussir
à s'en sortir et que la pauvreté en fait
ça équivaut à la paresse c'est parce
qu'on n'a pas travaillé suffisamment et
et comme on se méfie aussi beaucoup de
l'ingérence du gouvernement dans les
affaires des individus mais on n'aime
pas trop que les programmes sociaux par
exemple prennent un peu trop un peu trop
d'enfance dans la vie des ouais mais ça
ça suppose une chance égale mais c'est
ça à tous et pour la santé et je vais
vous entendre là dessus parce que c'est
un corollaire de la pauvreté la santé
qui est pas accessible
michel est ce que cette élection là est
quelque chose qui va peut-être changer
ou non sur cette histoire de la santé
sur la santé c'est clair que les deux
candidats des positions extrêmement
différentes
monsieur barry john veut préserver et
continuer ce qu'on a appelé obama qui
est à dire la la loi sur l'assurance
santé qui était passé dans le premier
mandat d'obama club s'en cache pas il
aurait voulu détruire obama rien au
complet et il dit qu'il ya une
alternative on n'a toujours pas vu mais
l'inégalité des revenus est la chose qui
est peut-être le plus grand de la plus
grande énigme en politique américaine
les américaines reconnaissent qu'un
problème là mais si vous leur demandez
là dans la liste c'est en dessous de
l'environnement c'est ça on va en parler
mais de façon incident par les questions
de taxation les questions de salaire
minimum de thomson comme jamais de santé
mais on parle jamais d'eux les corps des
revues santé ça arrive deuxième dans les
droits des patients américains est une
question de victoria tam qui est entré
quelles mesures envisagent joba donné
dans rome pour garantir un accès
équitable à une meilleure couverture de
soins pour la population
ce débat sur la santé comme un jeu
commence avec vous monsieur kraus
comment vous le percevez actuellement la
population américaine ne comprend pas la
complexité de ce problème
nous avons une demi douzaine de lois qui
ensemble régissent les soins de santé
aux états unis et les soins de santé aux
etats-unis c'est un système qui est
cassé les assureurs
les gens achètent les services de
médecins sans jamais connaître de prix
du service qu'ils achètent à cause des
assurances s'est cassé il faut que ce
soit aimé améliorer à la fois baden et
rome veulent améliorer mais des deux
façons différentes exactement comme le
dit michel by denver on augmenter le
contrôle gouvernemental
je veux que qu'il ya plus de concurrence
entre les compagnies d'assurances +22
d'éclairage de publicité de prix pour
qui la concurrence mais que deux
approches nettement différents joueurs
but même but
je vais aller à vous je suis curieux
parce que vous avez habite au québec
j'avais enseigné à l'université de
sherbrooke dont vous connaissez bien les
thèmes de santé canadien pourquoi il est
perçu comme étant un système socialiste
et c'est presque le diable car les
républicains parlent de ça oui vous
savez mes deux enfants sont nés au chili
au centre hospitalier de sherbrooke
alors je connais bien le système
je connais bien système par contre aux
états unis lorsqu'on veut un service on
peut la voir
le lendemain lorsqu'on veut je m'excuse
je connais pas le nom en français et
moraille magnifique
voilà on peut le voir le jour même ou le
lendemain
lorsqu'on veut voir un spécialiste ce
spécialiste est disponible cette semaine
ou la semaine prochaine dans cet accord
plus cher celui-ci fasse ça coûte plus
cher c'est plus efficace je n'installe
il a tu sur la santé je vous entends je
ne peux pas que je ne sais pas comment
pas commencer à le professeur klaus
connaît ce qu'il a décrit c'est
l'assurance maladie seulement pour les
riches et les très doué ici aux etats
unis ce qu'il a écrit bhl se décrit sa
oui c'est vrai si vous êtes à
l'université un noyau comme moi c'est
vrai si on a besoin d'un et moral ça va
arriver
et dans un temps quelques jours mais ne
décrit pas s'il vous plaît le système de
l'assurance maladie a entièrement aux
états unis comme vous viendrez les
fameux par l'assurance-maladie deux des
plus riches c'est pas la vérité c'est ça
seulement elle est universelle
ces zones et l'universel et y croyons
que le pays aussi riche que le nôtre
aussi riche que les états unis à des
millions de personnes qui n'ont pas de
l'assurance maladie
c'est affreux c'est une grande chute
c'est un abîme d'un système social et
c'est juste pas vrai que les américaines
tous aux accès de sept systèmes d'or ou
aux règles de comptage très content de
vous entendre monsieur naftali et
monsieur grave ça va parce qu'on a
vraiment on a eu quoi comme ça dure et à
sept minutes et demie deux on a eu les
deux visions qui s'affrontent depuis
quoi le fric obama a voulu réformer ce
système là de chanter et et on arrive
vous n'arrivez pas à régler cette
histoire là mais j'étais un curieux car
parce que vous avez quand même connu le
système canadien oui il ya des délais
peut-être mais tout le monde peut un
jour y arriver on va y revenir je veux
l'autre point important quand on parle
de l'économie c'est sa relation à
monsieur sommes avec le reste du monde
et avec la chine notamment
je joins en direct notre correspondante
en asie avec des héros vous vous trouvez
un et qu'il faut le dire à paris donc
c'est un peu plus doux pour le décalage
quoique oeil et art beaucoup
le président a toujours dit moi je vais
me tenir debout devant la chine
je vais négocier un accord qui va est
extraordinaire est ce qu'il est arrivé à
ses fins vraiment où finalement la
rhétorique est là mais les résultats
sont peut-être pas là écoutez j'ai un
peu de difficulté à vous entendre messi
est la question c'est si trempette
arriver à ses fins pour appliquer a eu
quand même un accord préliminaire qui a
peu eu beaucoup de suivi là en raison de
la coved en trop
rappelez-vous ed très tôt dès durant sa
campagne électorale en 2016 mais donald
trump avait fait de la chine une de ses
cibles préférées en disant que pékin
nuisait aux intérêts américains dont on
vient de passer à travers quatre années
de tensions économiques mais aussi de
tensions technologique qui en découlent
et on a en tête bien sûr l'exemple le
plus connu roi ou et le géant chinois
des télécommunications avec son
développement du réseau et 5 g alors
pour washington ils représentent une
menace à la sécurité nationale alors que
la chine a dit que les états unis
essaient de freiner ses avancées
technologiques donc quatre ans de guerre
de mots de tension diplomatique voire
militaires même sur plusieurs dossiers
on passe à ankang avec les sanctions
américaines qui ont suivi l'imposition
par pékin d'une loi sur la sécurité
nationale qui est jugée liberticide par
les militants pro démocratie et à la
question aussi des revendications
territoriales de pékin dans mer de chine
méridionale et bien sur taïwan alors le
régime chinois va de très mauvais oeil
le rapprochement
surtout ces dernières semaines entre
washington est un walking voit comme une
province rebelle qui veulent revoir à
revenir dans le giron dans son giron
dans son rêve de chine unique de grande
chine mais la chaîne aussi et c'est ce
qui est intéressant pour va se laisser
là dessus indique mais la chine veut
retrouver une grandeur aussi alors même
si by deux gagnants se priver les
relations ne seront pas nécessairement
mayer
voilà c'est pas c'est pas tout à fait
évident c'est trop facile face à cette
chine qui a adopté ce qu'on appelle une
stratégie diplomatique des loups
combattant pour défendre ses actions
pour pouvoir vanter son modèle face aux
démocraties
reste qu'une maison blanche démocrates
pourraient rester fermes quoi qu'en dise
donald trump rester aussi constante dans
ses positions notamment sur les droits
de la personne avec joe biden qui a bien
dit ces dernières mois il fallait être
dur face à la chine de la même traité
sujet ping de voyou il faut rappeler
aussi que sous barack obama déjà les
démocrates
et bien vous voulez essayer de centres
et de contrer les ambitions de la chine
en asie pacifique avec la stratégie dite
de pivot alors joe biden à la maison
blanche ce serait peut-être aussi plus
rassembleur raisin les alliés comptent
pour faire un front commun face à la
chine donc qui la chine qui a pu
profiter un peu de la division du camp
adverse et c'est 4 dinars à nice alors à
suivre avec bureaux à paris merci
beaucoup de cette collaboration
au revoir après la pause les tensions
raciales les afro américains iront ils
cette fois voté on sera à atlanta en
géorgie ou non mais qui ne veut rien
dire
il n'y a plus une file au but
le prix
oui
women est là
des images qui nous ont forcés à
comprendre que les tensions raciales
restent extrêmement vive dans ce pays et
surtout douloureuse pour les citoyens
noirs comme un cri encore de révolte de
désespoir c'est ça aussi deux amériques
une blanche et noire plus pauvres et
craintive 90% des électeurs noirs c'est
énorme pensent voter pour joe biden mais
encore faut-il qu'ils se rendent aux
urnes
la dernière fois beaucoup sont restés
chez eux azeb wolde giorgis s'est rendu
en georgie berceau de l'affirmation des
droits civiques
atlanta le berceau des droits civiques
aux états unis
cette ville d'à peine 500 mille
habitants a vu naître martin luther king
le symbole même du mouvement pacifiste
des années 60
à l'aube d'une élection aussi polarisé
les mots du révérend en orange jamais
raisonné aussi fort et les votes des
afro-américains jamais aussi important
il est notre inspiration atouts stewards
amos lee militant auprès du mouvement
black blues matters les électeurs noirs
compte l'objectif s'assurer que les afro
américains aillent aux urnes le 3
novembre
pas question de faire du porte-à-porte
qu'ovide oblige c'est désormais à la
sortie de centres d'achat qu'on tente
d'inscrire les électeurs
l'application et sur chaque véhicule
il suffit de la télécharger avec son
cellulaire une élection cruciale pour
tim site web qui arbore un triste ou
slogans faisant référence aux jeunes
afro-américains mort sous les balles de
policiers blancs dans notre champ perçu
ici comme un président raciste
mais c'est surtout dans les petites
communautés qu'il faut aller chercher
les électeurs souvent oubliés comme ici
à warner robben à 2h d'atlanta en 2010 8
750 mille électeurs n'avaient pas été
inscrits et la majorité était des afro
américains
on ne veut pas répéter la même erreur il
constitue 33 % de l'électorat et vote à
96 % pour les démocrates
et dans notre chambre ne veut pas de
leur vote
ici un mécano coeur de la georgie en
profitent de la distribution de paniers
alimentaires pour installer les bleus
chaque mois que nourrir une famille de 4
pendant sept jours
la file est longue
les militants de blagues douteuses
mature profit de la tante effective
s'inscrire c'est la première barrière à
franchir pour faire valoir son droit de
vote
le monde et en plus c'est à la
discrétion de l'employeur d'allouer du
temps pour aller voter
autant d'obstacles pour que les banques
en sorte qu'ils considèrent que
l'amérique de trump est un retour en
arrière
un deuxième mandat le fait frémir et
c'était il n'ya pas si longtemps
près de soixante ans plus tard le combat
pour l'égalité raciale continue aux
etats-unis
une mobilisation qui elle espère se
reflétera dans le taux de participation
des électeurs qui auront le choix entre
deux amériques
qui auront le choix entre deux amériques
question de monsieur ou madame flaubert
quel est le plan des candidats justement
pour combattre le racisme systémique et
la violence policière
ont-ils la ferme intention de le faire
c'est vraiment une
yann de ligne des dettes de démarcation
l'homme celle ci sur ces questions là on
l'a vu depuis trois semaines lors des
conventions et républicaine et démocrate
les républicains ont choisi le côté loi
et ordre et les démocrates disent on
comprends cette colère là en tentant de
se dissocier des débordements oui la loi
et l'ordre c'est le thème de monsieur
trame depuis depuis le premier jours
après les manifestations après la mort
de john slade
il a commencé la loi et l'ordre dès ce
moment là donc fait trois mois qui est
qui qui est qu'il est sur le même
registre
et là il va très clairement c'est les
banlieues qui sont visés c'est léon
cible l'électorat féminin en banlieue
qu'on croit plus vulnérables et c'est là
dessus que monsieur tron essai de de
fonctionner le problème c'est que ces
îles ne peut il ne fait pas bouger
l'aiguillé là dessus et tout le monde
sait qu'il est pour la loi et l'ordre
et là ça ne semble pas avoir la même
résonance
mais est-ce que karen prénom il n'y a
pas un danger pour les démocrates parce
qu'on a vu joe biden qui a tenté de se
dissocier des débordements des émeutes
en même temps il dit je comprends la
colère et la révolte des citoyens noirs
donc c'est un tabou qui n'est pas facile
à faire non plus effacer la femme je
pense qu'il est quand même fait de façon
de façon sensée c'est à dire que il faut
absolument prendre en considération les
causes de cette de cette révolte lorsque
les républicains et à la convention le
vus non pas faire on ne reconnaît pas
les causes la tante de cette violence là
alors on essaie de mettre le couvert sur
le feu ou on essaie de dire nous on va
se débarrasser de cette de cette
violence-là en visant effectivement les
banlieues comme le dit michel mais
bendhiba il faut aller un peu plus loin
que ça et symboliquement il a choisi une
colistière qui est noir donc c'est
envoie un message aussi en voulant dire
on va vous entendre vous vous écoutez en
même temps les afro-américains c'est un
électorat qui est assez
à ces démocrates généralement je pense
neuf cas sur dix la dernière fois je me
cherche encore reçu huit pour cent du
vote de l'électeur en noir mais madame
clinton son drame c'est que beaucoup ne
sont pas allés voter
exactement mais je pense qu'ils sont
davantage mobilisés cette année et je
pense qu on a vu davantage les effets
des restrictions au droit de vote aussi
qui affecte surtout les communautés afro
américains frédéric arnaud le rebond
soit la loi et l'ordre
ce n'est pas la première fois qu'on joue
avec ce thème lors d'une campagne
présidentielle voilà une formule très
républicaine très conservatrice monsieur
trump a bien compris qu'il fallait
suivre ce fameux mode d'emploi et donc
de présenter un peu l'anarchie qui lie à
dans les rues par exemple de portland ou
encore akhennouch à howie ce qu'on sait
donc ce qu'il fait aussi ses de
dépeindre son adversaire comme quelqu'un
qui est forcément mou dans des
publicités très négative
monsieur baden qui était un radical de
gauche qui ne fait rien qu il s
installer le chaos alors ces genres de
formule déjà utilisée par exemple par
george bush père mais aussi et c'est
quelqu'un qui l'a vraiment qui est
vraiment parfait on va dire la méthode
c'est à dire monsieur richard nixon en
1968 qui voulait se faire élire
justement sur le thème de la loi et
l'ordre il dit qu'il allait mettre de
l'ordre dans les rues faut dire que à
l'époque c'était quand même une période
très très forte très vivant tensions
sociales et raciales alors que monsieur
nixon se présentait comme candidat
républicain
il y avait beaucoup d'émeutiers va des
manifestations évidemment à cause bien
sûr de l'assassinât de martin luther
king en 1968 et dans quelle époque aussi
monsieur nixon avait sorti des
publicités très négative très grand
guignolesque où c'était vraiment le
chaos qui s'installait dans les rues et
ça évidemment fonctionner grâce aux
banlieues qui l'ont suivi les banlieues
évidemment qu'ils étaient très très
blanche à l'époque monsieur nixon a été
élu sur ce thème
aujourd'hui monsieur trump essaie de
faire la même chose mais a quand même
des différences fondamentales entre les
deux d'abord monsieur klein veut se
faire réélire une deuxième fois sur ce
thème avec un deuxième mandat alors que
monsieur exxon lui s'était dit ben ça ne
marchera pas finalement la loi et
l'ordre n'a pas été si bien respecté
pendant son séjour à la maison blanche
et non qui n'a pas risqué de faire la
même chose avec son deuxième thème de
de campagne et donc l'autre différence
c'est qu'en 1968 les banlieues étaient
presque exclusivement blanche
aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup moins
homogène on a des banlieues dans l'est
que l'on peut retrouver des latinos ou
des afro-américains résultat est bien
aujourd'hui alors que monsieur trump
porte ce thème de la loi et l'ordre qui
selon les américains est le plus apte à
fait respecté l'ordre dans les rues et
bien c'est joe biden selon les sondages
patrice très bien intéressant frédéric
michel si vous vouliez ajouter un petit
mot en 68 avait une chose très
importante c'est la guerre du vietnam
c'est l'éléphant dans la pièce et c'est
sûr qu'ils causaient des manifestations
souvent violentes ou si de la brutalité
policière
et il y avait eu l'assassinât de king on
l'a dit mais aussi de robert kennedy
s'était un temps un détail plus troublé
je pense de l'histoire moderne des états
unis mais n'empêche une celle ci vous
avez dit tout à l'heure les guînes n'a
pas bougé depuis la convention
républicaine avec ce thème l'offre qu'on
eu l'impression pendant quelques jours
que les républicains car une prime ont
martelé ça ils avaient des sondages ou
des appels des groupes de discussion des
fois que ce groupe en leur disant c'est
rentable quand même professeur pour rien
le les discours de trump et la veille du
vice président prenne c'était que
charles
oui mais c'est passé d'avoir des fois
que ce groupe qui dit ça fonctionne bien
c'est un discours qui marquait pour les
républicains aussi depuis toujours on
l'a vu sauf quelqu'un c'est vous qui est
président depuis quatre ans c'est
difficile d'accuser votre adversaire qui
n'est pas au pouvoir d'être responsable
de ce chaos là alors ça peut marcher
peut-être quelques jours où ça peut
marcher auprès de la base mais c'est pas
sûr que ça peut avoir un impact durable
je demandais à notre jeune ami michael
craché et timothy naftali qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
le sucre à bord est-ce que ce thème là
peut être porteur pour les républicains
vous savez une autre différence de 1968
c'est qu'en 68 presque tous les
policiers étaient blancs aujourd'hui
dans les grandes villes les chefs de
police
en majorité ce sont des afro américains
ce sont des chefs de police qui ont
démissionné en assez grand nombre depuis
deux semaines lorsque
les gouverneurs de différents états ont
projeté de d2 réduire
l'approvisionnement financiers des corps
policiers lorsque cela arrive lorsque
les chefs de police démissionne
lorsqu'il ya moins de policiers dans la
rue ceux qui souffrent ce sont pour la
plupart des noirs les minorités raciales
sont des victimes de crimes beaucoup
plus que ce sont les blancs et donc je
suis pas sûr je pense vous en parlais
tantôt des de l'effet souterrain des
sondages moi je suis pas sûr qu'ils
aient pas un grand défi souterrain qui
est des gens surtout des gens de race
noire ou des hispanophones qui ont vu le
saccage autour d'eux et qu'ils n'en
veulent pas qu'ils veulent qu'ils
veulent la paix il est possible qu'ils
choisissent de voter républicain
oui c'est quand même un point
intéressant de souligner parce que dans
les sondages il ya beaucoup de gens qui
ne disent pas tout et surtout c'est pas
très populaire de dire qu'on va voter
vous monsieur naftali qu'en pensez vous
de toute cette question comment elle
vient jouer
comment elle vient jouer dans cette
campagne voyait toujours des des
mouvements souterrains et on en attend
autant au jour de scrutin pouvoir qu'est
ce qui va arriver mais une chose très
importante en 1968
richard nixon s'est présenté comme
candidat il n'était pas au pouvoir il a
utilisé la politique de l'ordre et de
loi et l'ordre
parce qu'il n'était pas au pouvoir en
1972 il est il le président il y là il
n'a pas utilisé cinq hommes comme slogan
de campagne parce qu'il savait que comme
président il ne veut pas être
responsable pour le chaos ou pour cette
raison la campagne de 72 était la
campagne de paix je suis disait je suis
de peace maker c'est moi qui était en
train de négocier avec canoë
c'est moi qui est allé à bejing ou c'est
moi qui aie qui est allé à moscow il
comprenait en 1972
que comme président on ne peut pas se
présenter au monde au peuple dix ans
avec moi c'est celle loi et l'ordre
quand vous êtes entourés pavesi mute ou
par peur des débats une société qui
était en colère
ou alors c'est une raison pourquoi ça
vraiment ce site c'est quand tu dis toi
un président se présenter comme ça
premièrement deuxièmement il n'y a pas
beaucoup de sa cage
aux états unis il y avait il ya eu des
limites violent mais la plupart des
manifestations étaient pacifiques
très bien alors là une des raisons que
ça vous concerne marche pas c'est pas
c'est parce qu'elle passait pas la
vérité mais ça ne vous donne travers un
second pourquoi mais monsieur thiam n'a
jamais tenté d'apaiser d'abord de dire
je comprends la colère de mes
concitoyens noirs voyant ce qui est
arrivé dans les
oui ce conseil notamment pourquoi il n'a
jamais tendu la main d'après vous je ne
dirais pas qu'il n'a jamais tendu la
main
j'ai entendu quelques propos de sa part
qui était dans ce genre là mais vous
avez raison il n'a pas fait autant qu
aurait fait la plupart des présidents
des deux partis politiques c'est parce
que c'est pas l'homme c'est pas son
caractère c'est pas sa personnalité il
est lorsque lorsqu'on pousse il est là
il a le désir de repousser deux fois
plus fort de saint père jacques généreux
ces deux jeunes une fois plus fort reste
et là on doit faire une rose après la
pause c'est vraiment un phénomène
intéressant
on l'a connu ici à notre échelle des
gens qui déménagent à la campagne à
cause la pandémie mais pour d'autres
raisons aussi aux états unis compte tenu
du prix des maisons en trop qui a
beaucoup de gens des villes du nord qui
sont allés s'installer à la campagne
dans le sud campagne dans le sud des
territoires traditionnels républicain il
y en a tellement que ça commence à
brouiller les cartes
encore un élément qui rend cette
campagne encore plus complexe c'est
d'entre eux
et
je le disais avant la pause c'est un
phénomène qui brouille les cartes des
milliers de jeunes professionnels qui
quittent chaque année les grandes villes
du nord pour s'établir dans le sud moins
cher et plus conservateurs plus
républicain donc maxime la rochelle nous
a d'ailleurs posé la question est ce que
ça pourrait favoriser les démocrates
raphaël bouvier auclair est allé voir en
caroline du nord en mettant les pieds à
regarder le constat s'impose
immédiatement
la ville à l'effet d'un aimant
avec ses universités ses laboratoires et
ses entreprises technologiques la
caroline du nord attire bien des
américains ici 44 % des résidents sont
nés à l'extérieur de l'état et sa
famille ont choisi il y à 80 s'expatrier
dans la région de raleigh pour cette
new-yorkaise c'était un changement de
décor majeur un poids financier de plus
en plus difficile à porter
quand son mari a reçu une offre d'emploi
en caroline du nord la décision a été
simple à prendre lui même créé un blog
pour documenter son expérience et
éclairé d'autres new york est tenté de
déménager parce qu'elle n'est pas seul à
migrer vers le sud
kerry la banlieue où elle est établie
pour même le surnom de six zones de
confinement pour aix new yorkais
y'en a plus de gens de partout du pays
dans notre région présente chaque jour
en moyenne
on a 42 personnes qui viennent quelque
part pour s'installer comme ses
collègues l'agent immobilier kodjo
koussou et témoin privilégié de la
croissance de cette région où les
nouveaux développements pousse très
rapidement parmi ses clients des jeunes
professionnels évidemment mais aussi
beaucoup de retraités de santé et à
l'environnement et a aussi beaucoup de
vies parce que quand le monsieur prend
sa retraite et qu'il est menacé un
budget limité et verser quelque part où
le coût de vie ne va pas dépasser en
face on revenait manche et c'est une
fois à la retraite que joe alomene s'est
installé près du relais de son new york
natal il ne regrette rien même ici il
peut trouver des souvenirs de son ancien
chai nuit
quand il est arrivé jo avait des
appréhensions
des gens lent avec un accent ses prix
jugé à propos du sud se sont vus et
effacés
au delà leur nourriture les expatriés
new yorkais emmène avec lui une partie
de leur culture
la caroline du nord n'est pas le seul
endroit attrayant pour ces américains
qui veulent déménager là georges et la
floride l'arizona le texas
plusieurs états du sud et de l'ouest ont
connu d'importants gains migratoires ces
dernières années des changements
démographiques qui ont des impacts
politiques qui comme in from nous pour
cette experte c'est l'un des facteurs
qui fait en sorte que certains états
rouge change tranquillement de couleurs
en 2016 dans notre champ par emporter la
caroline du nord avec une marge d'un peu
moins de quatre points de pourcentage
dans cet état du sud ou tiers de la
population vit dans des zones rurales
le président a toujours de bons appuis
mais la partie n'est pas gagnée
la militante than bonne républicaine
convaincue reconnaît que les changements
démographiques représente un défi pour
son parti originaire de la caroline du
nord elle lance un message aux électeurs
démocrates qui ont adopté son état
huit ans après son arrivée à kerry l'ex
new yorkais sera au crédit ne changerait
pour rien au monde sur mode de vie quant
à la politique c'était les crises
libéral voit même des avantages à vivre
dans un état plus républicain
panetta en pleine transformation qui
pourrait être déterminant dans le
résultat de l'élection alors on ne va
évidemment pas tenter de prédire le
dénouement de cette campagne électorale
et en ça prendra on le dit un peu plus
tôt peut-être des semaines après le 3
novembre mais ce qu'on peut déjà dire
c'est que si jamais joe biden gagne
qu'est ce qui risque de changer on a
préparé des petits tableaux très sain
parce qu'après tout il ya quand même
deux propositions politiques très
différentes sur la pandémie
joe biden fait sa campagne en disant que
lui allait redonner à la science à place
mettre de l'avant la science est
respectée donc les conseils des
scientifiques des médecins commerce
international similaire à la position de
thuram pourrait-on dire
celle ci vous allez peut-être pas tout à
fait d'accord mais on va y revenir
politique étrangère rebâtir les ponts
avec les alliés sur l'environnement on a
parlé un peu plus tôt
ceux qui étaient avec nous byden promet
de réintégrer l'accord de paris et sur
l'immigration
là c'est vraiment très différent joe
biden dit augmenter le nombre de
réfugiés et on les a maintenant
augmenter le nombre de réfugiés
accueillis expulsé seulement les
coupables de crimes violents alors là on
a des différences de politiques qui
chelsea il ya des différences
fondamentales on le voit comme wii /
commerce international juste le petit
bout je voulais dire c'est que monsieur
ben dunn crois beaucoup plus que
monsieur jobs aux accords multilatéraux
et entre autres avec le canada ça ferait
une différence je consulterai renégocier
l'alena pendant pendant deux ans pour
revenir à peu près aux mêmes traités
puis on se mêlerait pas de la sécurité
nationale pour mettre des tarifs sur
l'aluminium et d'acier la met sur la
chine
effectivement il aurait probablement à
peu près la même approche sauf que le
multilatéralisme là dedans pour le
canada est une garantie et on va par la
madeleine tout à l'heure en direct
qu'est ce que ça pourrait changer pour
le canada
en prime on vous jette d'accord lyria
sur certains dossiers
il y aurait des changements de cap
important bien sûr et c'est surtout un
changement de discours aussi un
changement d'attitude notamment par
rapport aux alliés par rapport à la
diplomatie par rapport à ceux
multilatéralisme la nécessité de faire
des compromis mais aussi de faire des
gains pour les états unis parce que
quand on regarde ce que dans l'autre on
peut faire par exemple à l'international
il s'est retiré de certains accords il a
rencontré kim jong hoon des côtes il eut
en échange pour les états unis
c'est difficile à mesurer alors dans la
tradition un peu plus démocrate un peu
plus internationalisme libéral tel qu'on
connaît habituellement le la façon de
faire les choses depuis quelques
décennies mais il ya des gains peut-être
un peu plus substantielles en faisant
appel à nos alliés plutôt qu'en les
exclure
timothy naftali michael crash qu'est-ce
que dans votre esprit ça changerait si
joe boyd l'emportait le 3 novembre
prochain
vous pouvez choisir le sujet que vous
voulez michael kraft et écoutez je suis
prof de droit le plus grand changement
et ce serait remarquable ce serait dans
la philosophie jurisprudentielle des
juges nommés
non seulement la cour suprême mais au
cours inférieur fait dire à et vous
savez que chez nous aux états unis on
n'a pas de clause nonobstant dans les
lois il n'y a pas de loi qui prime la
constitution il ya des juges qu'ils
soient qui sont activistes qui peuvent
annuler bien des lois donc ce serait le
plus grand changement des débuts d'un
manga des jo bad est important ce que
vous dites je le rappelle dans les
motivations des voteurs républicain la
question de la nomination des juges de
la cour suprême arrive très haut très
haut et juste ça si on isole ça ça
pousse beaucoup de gens voter pour dans
notre homme monsieur naftali vous qu'est
ce qui changerait première mars le plan
de la politique étrangère les états unis
va jouer encore le rôle de à d'un allié
à et de d'un adversaire des dictatures
ça va être très dur
pour le chef de la russie ça va être
très dur pour la cheffe de la saudi
arabes et tous les autres dictatures
mondiale qui maintenant sont très
heureux qu'ils ont un ami à la maison
blanche grand changement
ça va changer à le climat mondial passe
et pas seulement pour les alliés mais
pour tout le monde c'est vraiment les
deux visions et c'est bien résumé
merci messieurs dames en altérer ce que
justement on va se rendre à moscou
on a passé quatre ans accusé la russie
d'avoir aidé à faire élire tram la
dernière fois jusqu'à quel point poutine
en a profité qu est ce qu il souhaite
maintenant c'est une réalité que poutine
fait tout en son pouvoir
en tout cas le kremlin pour que se tuant
presse à la maison blanche mais les
raisons qui motivent monsieur poutine
cette fois qu'on peut les mêmes qu'elle
était il ya quatre ans monsieur poutine
doit aujourd'hui après les faits dans
l'autre up un adversaire certainement
mais qui est mou qui est faible qui
s'est incliné qui prend des décisions
qui ont beaucoup avantagé la politique
étrangère de monsieur poutine dans
l'autre chambre déserté la syrie et a
laissé tout le champ libre à vladimir
poutine dans mon homme peut essayer
temporairement du moins de geler l'aide
militaire à la l'ukraine alors que
l'ukraine est en guerre avec la russie
monsieur trappe dénigre constamment et
critique des alliés internationaux en
europe et des organisations comme le
temps qui tient tête à la russie encore
récemment il était un des seuls à
s'opposer à de nouvelles sanctions
contre la russie donc tout ça c'est sûr
que ça avantage
monsieur poutine que monsieur drop sur
le plan personnel ça veut pas dire que
ça améliorer les relations entre les
deux pays mais sur le plan personnel
admire beaucoup monsieur poutine elle
l'a déjà dit son pouvoir son autorité
son patriotisme sa ruse ne vous pose la
question c'est quoi les avantages pour
le kremlin au moment où on se parle de
voir un nouveau président
tamara merci infiniment bonne fin de
nuit à vous merci beaucoup mario bédard
à paris on l'a évoqué il ya des bons à
rétablir avec les alliés avec l'europe
avec l'europe les relations a été mise à
mal depuis l'arrivée de dans notre âme
pour pouvoir sapin secret de
polichinelle il n'aime pas le multi
latéral isme et il s'est désengagé de
plusieurs désaccords qui avait été
négociée avec cet ami avec le continent
européen
les relations avec l'otan sont au plus
mal encore cet été il a annoncé le
retrait de 10 mille soldats américains
de l'allemagne il s'est retiré de
l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien qui
était une pierre angulaire de la
politique de coopération entre l'europe
et les états unis donc il ya des pots à
réparer maintenant est ce que la
relation entre les deux pays
elle a changé de façon irréversible même
si joe biden l'emportait aux élections
en novembre prochain
il ya quelque chose de fondamental qui
s'est brisée entre les états unis et
l'europe c'est à dire que ça pousser
l'europe à prendre de plus en plus
l'initiative de ses propres politiques
étrangères en négociant directement par
exemple sur certains enjeux avec la
chine
même chose du côté des pays de l'asie on
sait qu'on ne peut plus compter sur les
américains pour jouer un rôle de leader
mondial auquel ont pu se rallier merci
beaucoup
marie-eve bédard bonne fin de nuit à
vous aussi merci d'avoir été en direct
avec nous madeleine lémeret bonsoir
alors évident la marque pour nous cette
élection-là est extrêmement importante
pour les canadiens on reprendra pas la
blague de pierre trudeau là mais on est
là sourit à côté de l'éléphant est ce
que monsieur trudeau se lève la nuit
pour espérer que joe biden remporte 3
novembre prochain
lorsqu'il se lève peut-être la nuit pour
espérer que personne ne va dire quoi que
ce soit dans son gouvernement pour
afficher une préférence d'un bord ou
dans l'autre c'est vraiment le mot
d'ordre en ce moment à ottawa ya même
des ministres qui se sont fait rappeler
poliment dit on à l'ordre parce qu'ils
avaient affiché d'afficher des
félicitations via twitter lorsque kamala
harris avait été nommé co listière de
john dryden et on a rappelé à ses
ministres que c'est pas dans l'intérêt
du canada d'afficher des préférences
parce qu'on sait pas qui va à occuper la
maison blanche après le 3 novembre
prochain
mais même si le dira pas on s'entend qui
a probablement plus de proxim
était idéologique entre justin trudeau
et joe biden qu'avec dans l'antre ans on
en parlait tout à l'heure le changement
climatique par exemple de joe biden qui
veut réintégrer l'accord de paris ça
entre autres c'est ce sera un avantage
pour un justin trudeau qui s'apprête à
présenter un plan de relance qu'on croit
plus vert c'est vrai peut-être être plus
facile à vendre auprès des entreprises
canadiennes entre autres si c'est pas à
contre courant de ce qui se passe aux
etats unis merci beaucoup madeleine les
moins tard pour vous mais bonne fin de
soirée à vous merci beaucoup madeleine
le meurin ils seront nos yeux et nos
oreilles l'ont été tout au long de la
soirée d'ailleurs sur le terrain dans
les prochaines semaines que vont-ils
surveiller joint en direct nos deux
correspondants aux états unis jean
françois bélanger raphaël jean-françois
je commence avec vous qu'est ce que vous
allez particulièrement surveiller au
cours des prochaines semaines
d'abord il faut dire qu'il ya il reste
quand même presque deux mois ces
élections beaucoup encore se produire ce
qu'on va surveiller ses les débats il y
en a 3 le premier état criblé donc à la
fin septembre
trois débats 4 son compte le débat des
vice-présidents savez habituellement ça
change pas grand chose des électeurs
savent déjà à peu près à quoi s'en tenir
c'est peut-être l'épreuve la plus
importante en revanche pour dubaï donne
qui a beaucoup été dépeint par dans nos
jobs comme un vieillard sénile
finalement il doit essayer de faire
mentir donc cesser ces déclarations de
donald trump et c'est l'occasion pour
lui aussi de finalement d'apparaître
comme quelqu'un qui ne fait pas de gaffe
parce que vous savez les gaffes qui fait
joe biden il a cette réputation là est
bien l île et payer beaucoup plus cher
que celle de dans le genre sinon va
sauver aussi un autre truc des livres
vous savez il a inspiré beaucoup de
monde dans l'autre choc beaucoup de gens
ont créé des livres il ya encore deux
ans qui sortent dans les prochains jours
un écrit par son ancien avocat michael
cohen des révélations juteuses on a eu
quelques extraits il y en aura d'autres
la semaine prochaine ce sera à
surveiller ça peut être potentiellement
dommageable et où le livre aussi de bob
woodward celui qui a un qui est à
l'origine des révélations donc du
watergate
là aussi déjà quelques révélations vont
avoir prendre davantage aux cadences
yves la semaine prochaine
ce que ça va vraiment influencé c'est
loin d'être évident parce que vous savez
au moment où on se parle d'une bonne
partie des électeurs qui ont déjà une
opinion tout fait ça peut peut-être
influencé en revanche la petite frange
d'indécis vous savez dans une élection
aussi serrée que ça ça peut faire la
différence
oui tout à fait pu d'ailleurs c'est
exactement 1 2 3 pour chats et ça vienne
basculer d'un côté ou de l'autre à
walbourg vient et vous et c'est
justement pourquoi pas tres il faut
surveiller
il faudra surveiller le taux de
participation
à partir de quand les gens vont-ils
voter parce qu'en caroline du nord par
exemple on a déjà commencé à distribuer
les bulletins de vote
comment les gens vont-ils voter on va
surveiller évidemment l'impact du vote
par la poste
et puis moi j'entends au cours des deux
prochaines semaines aller faire un tour
dans les banlieues de grandes villes
dans ces états clés où il ya eu un
mouvement vers les démocrates en 2018
après beaucoup d'électeurs à appuyer
dans notre champ par 2016
est-ce qu'ils vont se ranger derrière le
président ou non ses électeurs ça
pourrait être important ça peut avoir
une influence évidemment sur cette
course à la présidence mais aussi sur
des luttes au sénat il faudra surveiller
ça aussi on parle beaucoup de la maison
blanche mais il ya aussi évidemment le
contrôle du congrès qui est en jeu et ça
pourrait jouer dans les banques
reffle merci infiniment merci à vous
deux pour vos reportages à tous nos
autres collègues c'était fort
intéressant là du vrai reportage terrain
merci beaucoup
on va se reparler beaucoup au cours des
prochaines semaines dernier tour de
table je commence avec vous ou michele
c'est roger vous surveillez croire au
cours des prochaines semaines lequel il
un indicateur que vous surveillez
vraiment tous les jours ci un éducateur
c'est la floride
il n'y a pas de façon pendant notre
homme de gagner sans la floride 6 1 et
encore sauvé ce que je sauvais vraiment
c est ce que monsieur tron fait un an
que j'attends ça est ce que monsieur
trump va faire quelque chose pour
élargir sa base pour aller chercher des
électeurs qui ne sont pas déjà avec lui
je pensais qu'ils allaient utiliser la
convention républicaine pour le faire il
ne l'a pas fait puis depuis ce temps là
ils ne parlent toujours qu'à sa base sa
balle ses 42 43 % hong hong pour 42 ou
c'est frappant lors de la convention
républicaine parle à sa base
et comme on dit l'expression à la mode
agrandir la taille
beaucoup a grandi en tout cas
visiblement pas carrément vous savez
quoi
j'allais dire exactement la même chose
parce qu'il est capable d'élargir sa
base
ce concept seulement ce qui est à peu
près 10% des gens qui ont voté pour
tschamber de messages qui hésitent cette
année alors ça en prend pas beaucoup
comme vous l'avez dit pour changer la
donne et je reprendrai en fait ce
qu'elle est ce qu'elle est vos collègues
ont dit tantôt ça veut dire
la participation électorale notamment
les courses au sénat parce que un
président et chante avec deux chambres
démocrate au congrès mais ça peut avoir
une incidence assez dramatique pour lui
use et on revient en contrepoids qui
donne de l'espoir à michel c'est au tout
début de l'émission sur le système
américain qui est quand même elles sont
des contre pouvoirs et des
contre-pouvoirs michael calce timothy
naftali une minute chacun vous
surveillez quoi précisément monsieur
crav oui pour que monsieur tron gagne
plusieurs choses doivent arriver à mon
avis dans un premier temps il doit
compter des points importants contre
monsieur byden lors des débats je pense
que c'est fort possible qu'il le fasse
il faut le faire il faut qu'il le fasse
dans un deuxième temps pour toi que
l'économie continue à s'améliorer
je pense que c'est fort possible que ça
se passe très bon ça se passe pour trump
dans un troisième temps faut qu'il y ait
du progrès pour un vaccin très bien bien
le résumé je me suis installé vous
qu'est-ce que vous aurez l'élection
présidentielle aux 7 aux états unis
c'est si actuellement 50 scrutin je
regarde les scruter dans à peu près dix
états les téléspectateurs ne ne se
raconte pas des sondages nationaux
ils ne sont pas intéressants et
importants regardez seulement les
sondages d état pour gagner paris
doivent gagner à peu près 10 à a et a je
les regarde et j'attends très bien je
t'envoie et on va attendre aussi merci
beaucoup de votre participation très
intéressant d'avoir les deux courants
comme ça qu'ils nous ont parlé en direct
et et franchement clairement karine
celle ci est toujours un plaisir
on va se retrouver lors des prochains
rendez vous parce que mesdames et
messieurs il y en a beaucoup deux
prochains rendez-vous premier débat à ne
pas manquer 29 septembre débat
présidentiel deuxième débat le 15
octobre troisième débat le 22 octobre
et évidemment tout ça va culminer le 3
novembre lors de notre grande soirée
électorale
c'est un rendez vous mesdames et
messieurs qui va peut-être jamais se
terminer
merci d'avoir été là j'aime bien
vasselin vous attend pour le téléjournal
merci à très bientôt